[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter
draco malfoy severus snape and a
particularly vicious spell
sektum sempra we all know the scene
half-blood prince
moody lighting tension in the air and
later
draco lying on the floor in a pool of
his own blood what sparked this madness
in the half blood prince harry's rivalry
with draco malfoy
moves on to the next chapter their
previous dynamic
which was fairly infantile and
inconsequential
suddenly becomes very real not only were
the boys now older
but the wizarding world had shifted it
was clear the darkness was coming
voldemort was on the rise to power and
this meant that draco's father
a death eater had certain expectations
of his son
it didn't help that in just one book
prior lucius was
imprisoned in azkaban something which
traco blamed harry for
with his father out of the picture draco
suddenly had to be the man of the house
he needed to be strong to represent the
house of malfoy
but in reality draco was still just a
confused boy
who had been indoctrinated into a life
that was oddly
unlike him before even arriving at
hogwarts draco is given a task by
voldemort
kill dumbledore no pressure his internal
conflict is painfully evident right from
the very beginning
he doesn't want to do these things but
he feels that he must
that it is his duty kicking things off
with a bang
draco beats up harry on the train after
arriving at hogwarts
setting the tone for their relationship
moving forward
fast forward to later in the book and
one of draco
harry's classmates katie bell is subject
to some sort of awful
unidentified curse after some close
inspection
it quickly became clear that the culprit
was what casey was holding
a cursed object called the opal necklace
it's later revealed that though katie
was the victim of the attack
it was never meant for her it was meant
for dumbledore
you see while on her trip to hogsmeade
katie was actually placed under the
imperius curse
by the three broomsticks innkeeper
madame rosemarta
the kicker here is that osmeter was
actually under the imperious curse
herself
a curse administered by none other than
draco malfoy
this brings us to further along in the
story in the hogwarts great hall
when harry is speaking with the now
recovered katy bell suddenly
however draco malfoy enters the room let
me preface this by saying that at this
stage
harry had already been skeptical of
draco who had been skulking around all
year
and acting particularly arrogant harry
uses the marauders map
to find draco who is now alone crying in
the boy's bathroom
when harry enters the two immediately
break out into a jewel
with harry ultimately winning after
using a rather new spell in his arsenal
sektum sempra though we had been exposed
to sektum sempra and harry's potions
textbook
this was the first time that we saw it
in action and boy oh boy
did it do some damage the sectim's
emperor is a vicious dark curse that
acts like an invisible sword
causing lacerations hemorrhaging and
cuts upon its target
often after being struck the target will
lay there motionless as they lose blood
unaware of just how dangerous the spell
truly is harry makes the poor decision
of blindly casting it
being hit by the curse results in draco
lying there motionless
in a pool of his own blood and the boy's
bathroom floor with harry standing over
him
completely unaware of what to do next of
course in the real story
snape shows up and saves draco because
snape was the inventor of the spell that
harry had used
he recognized it immediately and
fortunately
he knew the counter spell volnera
sinentor
but what i want to explore today is what
if harry sectim's emperor
the spell that he cast so ignorantly
ended up in the death of his childhood
rival
what if harry killed draco malfoy i
think the first question that needs to
be answered is
why did draco die in this scenario and
my answer for that
is that snape showed up just a little
bit too late
untreated the lacerations from sectim's
emperor can quickly cause a victim to
bleed out
and i'm of the impression that if snape
had shown up just a little bit later
than he did
that draco would have died i still think
that snape would have shown up
he just would have been too late of
course one important thing to mention
here
is that at this point snape was draco's
sworn protector
in the beginning of the half blood
prince snape enters into an unbreakable
vow with draco's mother
narcissa in which he swears to take on
draco's task
killing dumbledore in the event that he
is unable snape also agrees to protect
draco from harm
as best he can an unbreakable vow is a
binding magical contract
that connects two parties the purpose is
simple it is to bind a fellow which or
wizard to a promise
if you are unable to honor the promise
that you've made with the unbreakable
vow
you will die this raises the question if
harry had killed draco
then would the vow have killed snape as
far as i'm concerned
snape would have remained very much
alive in the event that draco died
i say this because harry killing draco
at least from my perspective
lies reasonably far outside of the scope
of his vow
snape agreed to protect draco from harm
sure but this is certainly an
extenuating circumstance
with draco dead and no responsibility
for draco's death on snape
snape's vow with narcissa would have
effectively been nullified
furthermore i think that after arriving
at the scene snape would have covered up
for harry
fully aware of the imminent backlash
that would occur after the death of a
student
snape and harry would have worked
together to create a false narrative
that effectively brought the blame back
to voldemort and the death eaters
dumbledore who knows everything would of
course know the truth
but there would be absolutely no reason
for him to oust towery
with draco out of the way there would no
longer be any reason or obligation
for snape to kill dumbledore the only
reason that snape killed dumbledore was
to save draco's soul
and now draco was dead however
dumbledore was still sick
he was cursed and his death was imminent
i'm a little
conflicted on what would happen at this
point but i think that
because dumbledore was so sick snape
would have still killed him
to prove his loyalty to voldemort
however this may have occurred a little
later on
next we need to look at draco's parents
i think that it would be an
understatement to say that lucius and
narcissa
would be devastated by the loss of their
boy draco was lucius's only son
the man who was next in line to continue
his bloodline
and narcissa well all of her bad
qualities aside
she was a great mother to draco and
before his untimely death
she did whatever she could to ensure
that he was protected
the pair would be devastated and i don't
think that it would take long for their
sadness
to turn into anger to turn into a lust
for vengeance
if voldemort had killed draco he would
have even been open about it
and lucius knew that therefore lucius
would have been able to deduce
that someone else killed his son harry
potter
in order to acquire proof for this
inference lucius would go to voldemort
and have him perform legitimacy on harry
confirming the murder of his son
at this stage lucius and narcissa would
be on the warpath
dead set on killing the boy that took
their son away from them
it wouldn't take long for them to have a
crack and retribution either
as after the death eaters infiltrate
hogwarts narcissa and lucius would gun
straight for harry
with harry cornered lucius would have
the killing curse on the tip of his
tongue
just like in the film adaptation of the
chamber of secrets
however with the curse just about to
leave the tip of his wand
lucius would be hit by a killing curse
himself a curse belonging to voldemort
i told you to save me the boy voldemort
would scoff as he stood over the body of
lucius malfoy
with harry and his sister looking on
completely in shock
if there's one thing that voldemort is
it's overconfident
and he would have never felt that he
would need lucius to kill harry
lucius tried to take what was his to
kill and he would have punished lucius
for that
ultimately draco dying wouldn't have
much of a bearing on the court of the
story
dumbledore would have died at a
different time harry's crime would have
been hidden
and draco's father lucius would have
suffered his fate at the hands of
voldemort
what would later come of harry when all
of the dust settled
and what killing draco would do to
harry's psyche however
is perhaps another video altogether what
do you guys think
did i miss something let me know in the
comment section
below if you enjoyed the content please
like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you